non perderti anita stories la serie
animata un nuovo episodio ogni domenica
alle 12 sul mio canale
o no lei evento va bene benvenuti
serenità e solidale e oggi nuova
challenge slime mistery box nel
calendario dell'avvento challenger
cominciato in realtà perché era già al
lancio per me era non distruggere tutto
questo muro di stare molto attenti a non
farli cadere chi le fa cadere partire
l'azione della piana attaccamente in
ognuna di queste scatole c'è un
ingrediente slime in alcune ci sono
degli ingredienti sra emozioni belli e
in alcune si sono degli ingredienti
slide bruttini alla fine del video
vincerà chi avrà lo slime più bello e
voi dovrete votare nel sondaggio
wow we're foro da che dato sa chi ha
vinto in base alla bellezza ispo niente
mr dello slide sarà più fortunato in
pratica come segniamo el il numero
cancelliamo decidiamo di girare la ruota
vedete che ci sono margini della rosa
oppure possiamo tirare il dado oppure
possiamo scegliere loro che vogliamo che
la camera
lasciate un bel mi piace se voi avete a
15.000 se faremo un'altra sale slime
consigliate seppure nei commenti chiara
che challenge volete vedere
mettetevi cosi breve di bocca ha
iniziato subito lontana e andiamo nei
primo turno vediamo chi nyt carta forno
successo comincio io allora confluisse
dire la scatolina alla ruotolo dai gira
ed è un pochino
tra l'altro questa è anche una challenge
come quella di geni che mi sembra che si
chiama non lo so che devi cercare di
prendere le scatoline funzionari alla
ridurre che si vabbè allora ho perso 5
st sotto come vai a prenderlo senza
distruggere tutto per cui pian piano
aspetto esposto la bomba natura dove
guardano l'edificio non è difficile ma
neanche facile troppo ci aspetta non può
aprirlo ancora perché arato compagnia lo
seguo di tirare il tiranno sul buono mi
raccomando perché scale d'uso 1 bloccato
perché altrimenti avrebbe fatto cadere
tutto comunque uscito uno scarafaggio
togliere nulla dove sta a lui ci sono
questa regola che non devi far cadere
tutto allora per la mia idea
no io aiuto ok sono fatta per fortuna ii
caduta
ok andiamo a vedere cosa c'è nelle
nostre mister bob bryan cattura uno die
apri ma mi piacciono i flick rosa si è
trovato l'acqua la hembert viola e b
generalmente un colore che sufficiente
per il tuo slime è cominciato bene
questa volta albero vediamo quanto tempo
vi mandiamo a mettere i nostri
ingredienti
noi iniziamo che abbiamo già un pochino
di colla trasparenti e quindi abbiamo
già una base quindi dai diventerà viola
speriamo che non mi capitino e
bellissime flakes rosa a mera piacciono
però ancora non mischiamo lo mischiamo
dopo per vedere da vicino come diventa
scegli voi girati a berlino la
partecipazione ciao ciao
aiuto aiuto ma tu non mi hai dato quindi
enti aiuto
[Musica]
no non è questo il 97 troppo forte
perché c'è pure berlino dietro che si
sta agitando ma credo che ti sei
mangiato il file fuori che non sei altro
ovviamente merlino adora stare davanti
alla videocamera davvero anche lui uno
youtuber aspettavo tocca me adesso
questa volta voglio cedere il numero
scelgo dell'urp è finito numero 2 dove
non lo vedo da vendola versace la posso
fare
berlino allora dati aiuto gratin numero
due per adesso per carità ma problemi
vabbè colonna di aiuti ma oggi e tre
momenti la maledizione del verde ha
iniziato con vitale io invece ho trovato
dei fiorellini dei fiorellini molto
brillanti sono molto contenta di non
meno male che le prostitute scappare un
peso euro
per l'inter verde e allora vado a
mettere il fiorellino di io metto i
glitter verdi e belli ci stanno molto
bene lo sa il piccolo non sono invidioso
l'anno hai un po ma io sono molto
contenta permise relini ok dalle carte
ecco la stessa i knicks sono indeciso se
girare di nuovo la ruota se scelgo il
numero io però in a ho deciso di girare
la ruota
mi mancava la ruota 44 mino è che la
claque questo così io lavoro aiuta però
io ho trovato di aiutato era bene eccolo
qua berlino che stai facendo come voi
questo è questo ecco ancora grazie dove
ho quattro attaccanti sceso di tiro nel
chiudere mi portato studio dove no 10
anticato pochissimo 10 e qui dai ti
aiuto prendete grazie 44 apriamo il 4
anna che colore verde
in realtà è che se mai più berta che
turchese io invece ho preso di vitter
arancioni e belli legge che converte
stanno benissimo come diventerà poi
tutto mischiato questo slide sfera
stranissimo secondo me io lo so come
diventerà il tuo brutto
ok toccate nuovamente allora lasciando
loro 8 perché perché no per me numero 88
in realtà è uno dei miei numeri
preferiti sembri 18 mesi a berlino
berlino a 10 mesi di cella numero di
falsi 11 certo che vediamo un po cosa
abbiamo anche dentro le rosse rosa de
rosa fila con helmets viola un momento
perfetto e trasparente con i glitter
sempre e penso di farvi nvidia è uscito
galaxy brutto meglio dei pallini non si
lasciano il pepe rosa che lo metto come
pepe rosa e non fa niente ho fatto mette
la colla coni ditte non vedo l'ora di
vedere come diventerà ma che a te non
hai un continuato il dato infatti questa
volta scelta di tirare il dado veniamo
mi sono cadute non sono mai uscito il
numero 3 scrivete nei commenti se sono
caso il temperamento amico perché sto
crescendo tutti i numeri che stanno solo
ringraziare lei fatta carrello 333
voglio attirare chi è dato da 4 a mano
cosa che ho preso io il numero 23 che sa
questo per così non devo far chiedere
niente bello pesante
noi apriamo che cos'è pigmento verde non
ci posso credere gramenzi del display io
sono qui ha detto sono contento sapete
perché perché mi uscirà il famosissimo e
desiderato slime di natale ci sono anche
le palline rosse
quindi lo style albero di natale di
natale e vitale e si vedeva la
differenza di natale
sono troppo contento infatti cominciato
io invece nuovamente una colla tutte le
cose
giro io pratico di vita le metto anche
il pigmento le mette la colla blu lo
slime di natale sta per arrivare
non vedo l'ora di vedere come sarà ma
che tocca a te cosa scegli guardado
ok stai attento va bene non sono stato
io è uscito il 44 non c'e quindi il
ritorno quella ruota è inizata berlino
berlino che stava lì che soffia il
numero 7 che non c'è sì c'è eccolo qui
riuscito ad un progetto di essendo il
numero 20 ok vediamo un altro
ingrediente per lo slide di natale della
venere ti capitano i colori natalizi
pigmento rosso dei glitter blu graphic
mettono paura e lo faccio diventare
marrone ma non c'è problema batteria
l'albero di natale cioè troccoli un
motore stanno capitando tutti i colori
per fare il galaxy che fortuna pensavo
che questo challenge sarebbe stata
disastrosa invece sta andando abbastanza
aspettano nord in loro io scelgo il
numero 18 come la mia età perché sono
diventato maggiorenne
miller 19 vediamo ha detto un altro
moglie evidente per nulla di male
no vabbè veramente ci stanno capitando
glitter celesti galaxy ne ho visti tutti
come cyrano slide bellissima anche se
siamo vicini alla fine 124 come la
regata non era 18 18 quando sono
diventato maggiorenne da traguardare 22
vediamo allora questa volta mi andata
così così perché abbiamo sempre i
glitter di natale però c'è un colore che
non è solo per le due ingredienti c'è un
colore che non è fortunato di noi
facciamo grandi o meno 5 e allora un
pigmento color pesca è una pesca
allora io un pigmento celeste si può
stare in programma i suoi dei cuoricini
bianchi non si stanno molto bene vista
andiamo a metterli adesso ha detto pochi
si può essere carino o meno è caduto un
sacco estranee proprio di natale sembra
che stiamo facendo tipo una pozione il
camper ore 10 per barreto ecco qua i
cuoricini wow però è stupendo finora non
vedo l'ora di farvi vedere quando non
mischiamo st magari cambia completamente
la lotta a casa cerco casa 100k 13
anch'io serve a casa allora questo è
pesante
ma che cos'è non è un ingrediente slide
di natale devono ingrediente brutto e
cattivo cordero
la polverina tipo zucchero senza fare lo
slime granuloso non mi piace
bene tuffo non è giusto però perché ci
sono gli ingredienti così brutti ht
allora vado ad essere il mio zuccherino
non metto troppo senza mia completa ed è
brutto
vedremo una volta attiva quale sarà il
frutto è il buono e uno a caso il
professor donne sono cadute non sono
cadute 14 preso 14 21314 vuole scelga
brava numero 6
dai un pochino un pochino il gran tifo
le palline di natale e che stia giocando
tutto a tema ha aggiunto to bruciarsi
credibile però può essere che sotto
mischiato diventi un marrone perché ci
sono troppi i colori non dava un'altra
foto di questo perché se non me ne penso
sempre per strada a caso la mischia poi
bene mancano solo quattro fratellini
direi di prenderle tutte e due astenuti
adesso mi prendo tutte e due insieme
non mi confidano quando hai detto con
questa pesante meglio dire quindi me ne
sono lasciate una cosa mettete tutte io
le colle però anche questo sliven di
natale live e non ci credete non mi è
capitato nessuno perde non aspetti
magari vado a mettere la colla rosa io
dovevo prima mettere più a nord però
proprio un mix di colori questo slime è
bellissimo vedere tutte queste cose
insieme non mischiate e già ultimo
ingrediente per me come non mi piacciono
però ci stanno bene i gialli per me
ultimo il tridente è pesantissimo ho
paura
cos'era cosa fortuna che non ci posso
credere che ci è capitato tutto a tema
theatre uscirà sicuramente roseline
galaxy dio forse farò uno slide di
natale non so come uscire da questo che
c'è il nero
ora vi possiamo vedere come sono tutto
questo i colori andiamo li vediamo di
che colore diventa guardarsi un po che
meraviglia tutto questo mix di
ingredienti e colori c'è tantissimo
celeste ma sia anche molto viola bianco
ed aver stupendo andiamo mischiarlo
vediamo un po come dire cantante wow ma
che bertona sembra uno slam sirene
il siena come ariel non si capisce cosa
sta diventando ma sembra proprio un
bellissimo galaxy il preferito di vitale
alla fine è diventato un colore mi
sembra una sorta di note blu viola meno
male avevo paura che diventasse un
marroncino strano invece è diventato un
colore stupendo che è giusto ma tu hai
lo slam di natale lei sempre voluto fare
quindi eccolo qua il live di natale
portata quanto è bello altro che ha come
tema le tutte le palline decorazioni
visitatori quanto è grazie grazie
sono stato molto fortunato ma anche
molto bravo e molto coloranti aspetta si
deve girare verde
il nero lo sta facendo diventare marrone
che di certo marrone lo sto facendo
diventare marrone e un punto errato però
dai si curava il tempo insomma che sia
uno slide di natale sicuramente www il
lettorato lo tiro io pensavo io speravo
uscisse verde anzi ne è uscito dorato da
in un male non male ma nel frattempo io
ho fatto un po di casino perché regole e
ora procediamo ad attivare i nostri
slime così potrete scegliere il
vincitore pronti 32 st ecco quel news
live mentre vi faccio vedere il mio
bellissimo slime vi ricordo che domenica
alle 12 esce il primo episodio di enisa
stories la serie animata esse alle ore
12 quindi mi raccomando non perdete però
perché è una figata
e bellissimo e tutto animato a volte
anche disegnato e una storia fantastica
quindi mettete la sveglia domenica alle
12 il primo episodio vieni testori sulla
serie animata ora vi faccio vedere il
mio slime allora sono super contenta del
colore è uscita una sorta di celestino
però un po metallizzato guardate un po
purtroppo i fiorellini cuoricini non si
vedono perché non è appunto trasparente
per guardate come lucido wow sentiamo
invece un po di sony
[Musica]
pensavo che sarebbe uscito una schifezza
con tutti quegli ingredienti mischiati
invece sono state abbastanza fortunata
vediamo ora le prime e di natale di
vitale che fa arriva protti ma che il
colore stupendo un po verde un po dorato
ci sono le palline rosse tira talent i
glitter la stella cometa che costeggiano
le mie di stato tutti dentro lo slime è
bello morbidoso un po trasparente un po
dorato notare tutte le decorazioni
all'inter lo è adesso sentiamo qualche
assumono allora il poc in pochi non
funziona però sicuramente le bollicine
saranno spettacolari almeno quello che
un pochettino si va poco poco non
tantissimo e questo è il mio slime non è
uscito proprio benissimo ma nemmeno le
falli e non sono cadute esatto è
stupendo crede la marmitta le perché
bellissimo guardare slime twist di
natale e questo lo vediamo un po
mettiamole affianco a confronto
è questo il mio bellissimo galaxy cene e
questo il mio bellissimo galaxy tirana
le quali il più bello il vincitore del
santo ma scusate il vincitore ora milan
si è avuto a quattro cartellini a su cui
cliccare per vedere i vostri altri video
cliccate su quello che preferite è buona
visione